[Music]
officials gathering at the ronald reagan
presidential library to discuss security
challenges both at home and abroad
special report anchor and author of to
rescue the republic ulysses s grant the
fragile union in the crisis of 1876 bret
bear sits down a little later with
defense secretary lloyd austin it's
coming in just a few hours you want to
watch that but first he joins us live
now from simi valley hey brett thank you
for taking time tell us what is
happening there
good afternoon tell me what you want to
ask the secretary about
brett you got me got a big
we've got a big day ahead here just
dropped out there but um
listen the sitting down with the defense
secretary
gives an opportunity doesn't do that
many interviews actually uh and he's
going to be obviously dealing with a
host of issues he gives prepared remarks
first
that we're told will be really focused
on china and perhaps a different tone
about china than he has had and the
administration has had uh before we'll
watch for that uh but then i'll follow
up uh with him for about 20 minutes in
front of a crowd here at the reagan uh
defense forum and obviously we'll carry
that live on fox news channel the
breaking news is the efforts by russia
and what you just heard some 100 000
troops almost on the eastern ukrainian
border what does the u.s do if putin as
u.s intel suggests does move in in early
2022.
brett are folks there talking about
really how significant this russia news
is as it pretends as you mentioned
perhaps to china for instance what's
china going to do go into taiwan if
putin is not stopped from going into
ukraine are these conversations you're
hearing out there
a lot of them and a lot of people tied
to the defense industry or congressman
tied somehow to the administration have
real concerns about what russia and
china are doing and actually the
the link between the two and the
relationship between the true two you're
right the u.s military faces a lot of
things but if russia moves into ukraine
if china moves into taiwan what does
that look like what is the u.s response
those are very complex answers
for this administration and ones
well pose to the defense secretary in
one way or another in a little bit
and brett i've got to believe that
people are talking and contrasting
perhaps the different approach that
president biden is taking with president
ronald reagan last night on special
report you played for our viewers a
sound bite of president reagan in 1983
to speak to evangelicals i want to just
play that again for our viewers today
and get your reaction here is president
reagan in 1983
in your discussions of the nuclear
freeze proposals i urge you to be aware
the temptation of pride the temptation
of blithely
declaring yourselves above it all and
label both sides equally at fault
to ignore the facts of history and the
aggressive impulses of an evil empire to
simply call the arms race a giant
misunderstanding
and thereby remove yourself from the
struggle between right and wrong and
good and evil
brett as you listen to former president
reagan and compared to what we hear from
president biden today what are your
thoughts
well listen when we come to this forum
every year and fox has been coming for a
number of years
that is in the background you know uh
what ronald reagan has president said
and did with the soviets back then and
around the world
it was stark it was black and white now
there's a lot of nuance when uh talking
about russia and china and there are
some people here who wanted to be more
like reagan obviously but then there is
another side of the country that's very
concerned about getting the u.s involved
in another armed conflict or several at
the same time and can the u.s military
handle that those are all things that
are really being discussed here at this
forum in various panels throughout the
day
and brett we also i assume we'll hear a
little bit from secretary austin about
iran and there really demands at this
point over a renewed
nuclear agreement
yeah it seems like that's falling apart
the state department is saying or at
least projecting griff that
it's not going well and iran's not
bending to
a new nuclear deal i think there's a lot
of things to focus on the world is a a
lot of hot spots
and then you have
the issues internally about mandates for
vaccines in the national guard the fight
with oklahoma what florida is doing a
lot of topics that we'll get to here
with the defense secretary i just hope
we have enough time
i hope they give you a lot of time with
the secretary just i think you know for
our viewers to preview what's coming
here in just about two hours what do you
hope most to get out of the secretary to
hear from him
listen i think it's just
blunt questions uh answers that
hopefully the the administration can
provide on some of these issues to
provide context about what we're looking
at around the world
again he doesn't do that many interviews
and to get an insight from the defense
secretary is a really unique thing
hopefully we'll be able to cover a whole
bunch of topics but the most pressing
ones obviously we'll lead with first
chief political anchor bret baird taking
time for us out in simi valley brett
thank you and we will be tuned in and
all of our viewers should stay tuned
because brett will have a lot more to
say and talk about with secretary of
defense lloyd austin that's coming up in
the 3pm hour from the reagan national
defense forum in simi valley and you can
catch of course brett on special report
monday through friday at 6 pm on the fox
news channel